we are asked which of the following
describes a good that is likely to have
the most elastic demand
choose one answer so pause this video
and see if you can answer that
all right so the first choice right over
here they talk about a luxury with many
substitutes so we already talked about
when we're dealing with substitutes if
there's a lot of substitutes that makes
the quantity demanded very sensitive to
price so this would make it more elastic
to have many substitutes more elastic
and then the fact that it's a luxury
it's not something that people need this
would also make quantity more sensitive
to price generally so we would also say
more
elastic
so this is looking like a good candidate
but let's check the other options here
a necessity with few substitutes well
this is the opposite if it's a necessity
this would be more inelastic or less
elastic
less elastic
and few substitutes if you have a change
in price for that thing people say well
i still have to buy that thing i can't
substitute it with other things this
would also be less
elastic and remember we're looking for
the most elastic demand so we can rule
this one out
a broadly defined good such as food well
we just talked about that if we're
talking about food and that there's a
price change in food well we need food
so our quantity demanded might would not
likely change or a percent change in
quantity would not likely be that much
this would be fairly inelastic rule that
one out
goods that make up a small share of the
budget
well this goes back to the example with
bubble gum if bubblegum goes from 25
cents to 30 cents we might not care so
much versus if a car goes from 25 000 to
30 thousand dollars so the small things
that we might not care about price
changes so much if we don't care so much
about price changes that would imply
less elasticity so that definitely would
not be the most elastic demand
goods that have to be bought under a
short time constraint
well a good example is that it's raining
and people need umbrellas right now and
you know the next five ten minutes
and there they might they wouldn't
necessarily be so sensitive to price so
this is going to be less
elastic and so once again we would rule
this out if we had a long time frame
well then people might be able to shop
around for substitutes and then things
might get a little bit more elastic they
would be more sensitive to price so we
definitely like in this scenario choice
a